but guys for us on all the social media
Instagram Twitter Facebook Francisca
Foster constant kissing trigger pod
follow us all that's on kill it already
come on follow us follow us follow us
yes you're here now can you hear us now
can you hear us now Anton let us know
let's see okay you see it's a globalist
leftist Shields trying to silence us but
we won't be stopped we will get we will
rise above it and will we yeah of course
how are we going to do that mate what do
you mean we've got no [ __ ] sound I
mean we do now yeah we do now that's
proof that they tried to silence us all
the pedos on their Island and they
couldn't [ __ ] do it
I think it's no way to refer to Anton
despite his main mistakes yeah he's I
wouldn't call Anton ipido on an island
no I'm referring to that look those boys
what boys you know what they all went to
the island didn't they well the
Epstein's in there yeah exactly how is
Anton connected to them he's the one
that ruined our sound mate no I don't
believe that how do you know that he's
just watched him [ __ ] it up right in
front of you how do you know that he's
not in cahoots with them
that's a good point you don't know do
you everybody needs an angry Greek
Everton supporter on their team exactly
yeah he's taking photos of us now yeah
exactly going to send it to the pedos
man yeah exactly that's what he's going
to do did you see that bit of stand up
from Maurice shaffir no we so Ari is
obviously a Jewish man and he was like
you know people often say that you know
Jewish people you know we're very
successful and they use it as a stick to
beat us with and my friend said to me uh
Ari Epstein was Jewish and he went yeah
but if you're going to have the most
successful Peter
gonna be Jewish that's going to be top
of the list it's going to be top of the
list strong opening there mate I think
so as well unlike your the team you made
me watch last night so we we ended if
you remember if you were here last night
right yeah we did the Royal an hour
earlier than usual yeah and we went to
watch England play the USA yeah we went
into one of those classic country pubs
to watch it we did indeed how was your
fish and chips it was distinctly average
yep good
um but uh we went to see England play
the USA France we did it started
incredibly yeah because England took the
knee yeah and the USA didn't yeah the
USA where George Floyd happened yeah big
well they've forgotten about George
Floyd yeah they don't give a [ __ ] but
we're supposed to yeah but not yeah we
still kneel and that's what you're meant
to do you're meant to go to a country
literally thousands of miles away yeah
from where you live and even further
away from where the murder of George
Floyd happened yeah right you then kneel
in this Stadium built on the on the
deaths of six and a half thousand
migrant words you literally kneel on
them yeah you literally kneel on them
and then in the corner there's a gay
blood getting beaten up right and then
it's all good you've solved everything
that's how it works uh but Francis uh my
uh my opinions on the fish and chips and
English ice cream are well known yeah
right let's talk about your football
team mate yeah all right come on man
what was that well do you mean what was
that absolute gash
it was dog [ __ ]
I was so so bad you couldn't even beat
America and America you've got to
understand how they picked the team
right you know that kid in class that no
one wants on their team yeah right they
collect them from around the country
yeah and then make a football team out
of them and you still couldn't beat him
no we couldn't beat him we could not be
it was [ __ ] embarrassing having said
that we've never beaten the United
States at football I can see why
we've been we've never they've been us
more than we've beaten them true fact
we've played them three times drawn two
lost one
mate I don't know this is another reason
embarrassing it's another reason why I
think we should move to America the
soccer's better
you're such a cut
so there we go uh we we did go to May by
the way there's yellow cushions make you
look like the pancetta's back because it
sort of widens you yeah it does but I
don't care mate because I know that I'm
not I'm in the best shape of my life I
mean that's a tragic thought mate yeah
I'm at fighting white mate
fighting what diabetes
sorry the joke was too old yeah of
course but yeah so I'm a fighting white
I'm like the best I've ever been Anton
keeps commenting about my new figure
does he yeah what does he say you got
more to lose yeah no he keeps using the
words felt to describe me
and Tom has never used the words felt in
his life but anyway we went to watch
England play yeah they were [ __ ] yeah oh
mate they were atrocious it was an hour
and a half of my life that I'll never
get back no right I went along mainly to
to support you two yeah right after
about 40 minutes I wanted to strangle
you both and go home yeah strangle you
to save you watching the rest of it
obviously oh yeah well that's fair
enough it was that bad it was and I kept
thinking Anton the internal Optimist was
like yeah it's going to get better by
the way shall we uh review our
predictions for the game yeah okay Anton
what did you say
Anton said 4-1 England you said two one
England and what did I say it was said
he was going to be a draw and then but
you were negged on that and then you
said something else no I didn't I just
said it was going to be a draw
I didn't reneg on the truth no he did
this is how [ __ ] the game was you know
how much I love to be right yeah I don't
even take any pleasure and be right it
was that [ __ ] the game was utterly
approved it was bad now I'm gonna ask
you this question ladies and well
there's no ladies here gentlemen yeah
right predictions for England Wales on
Tuesday
I'm gonna go for one oh
that would allow England to qualify yeah
it would allow anything to call what
about you Anton
IA 3-1 England I actually think it's
going to be a draw again what do you
think it's going to be
a draw
no but you've got to say specifics no I
don't yeah you don't no I don't I want
to be right I was right last night I'm
gonna be right on Tuesday
there we go uh anyway welcome one
welcome all enough about the football
which was [ __ ] yeah boys it was
absolutely diabolical I've watched a few
games this world cup Germany Japan yeah
brilliant I want your second half of
that incredible do you epic Japan one
two one I watched uh what else should I
watch Iran why I also watch the last
half an hour of that [ __ ] blinding
that was in Iran beat with a Welsh in
your face all right man get the flat cap
out okay for the ladies okay I'm gonna
get the Fright cap out and that was
basically what I'm saying is that's the
worst game of football I've ever seen
Laura Mars matches then well she said
she says where was he going to smash us
I have decided
they're not going to smash us they don't
even they've got no decent prize Gareth
Bale is about 68 in just basically
hobbles around the pitch
useless anyway unlike England yeah it's
true anyway welcome one welcome all
we've got lots of great stories to talk
about today uh lots of stuff to discuss
we've got paid
yeah going in super chats we have some
unboxing to do because we tidied up the
studio a little bit as it's
slowly but surely making its way towards
completion so we found a couple of
things that you beautiful bigots have
sent us that we will unbox as well but
we have Francis get the bigot hit I
found the second biggest certificate in
here oh yes yes
it says friends
let's get some safety freaking flakes
it's a [ __ ] that he says uh with the 51
pounds 46 pins he says it seems as if
the Empire is busy striking back in the
springboks beat him a busy giving
England a proper pegging in the rugby
Eddie Jones is a nice bloke but he
should go and [ __ ] himself I mean that's
I mean I'm gonna say something Francois
on brand mate on brand indeed but let's
get some CC freaking conflicts let's get
in the chat let's get some spring box in
the chat uh up Francois about you're
going to ask you a serious question
you're you're a big South African fan
um I was reading a little bit because
obviously Dolly weird passed away sadly
today former Scottish legend mentioned
rugby Legend of mnd and uh your own
Springbok Legend just Vander West Haven
passed away from mnd a few years ago now
incredible rugby player that he was he
was brilliant would you recommend the
the movie on him oh because I I saw I
saw that there was a movie or a doc on
him if you've seen it would you
recommend it but what rugby play was and
a top shagger as well um yeah massive
man this cushion is triggering me why is
it so high oh it's because yours is low
because it can't handle the amount of
pressure on it what are you talking
about there we go no it's still hot yeah
you're gone there we go mate get with it
get with the program your cushion looks
like it's just
mate he's having a good [ __ ] time
no it's embracing get off me it's
embracing me because it [ __ ] loves it
all right uh yeah I'm sure that's
happened mate yeah all right Anton let's
find out what the beautiful bigots are
saying uh in the chat for Frankie Noir
yeah is it true Dougie the Murray is no
longer living in the UK we're not going
to dogs Dougie Murray live on a raw show
no not for two pounds anyway it's just a
proper Super Chat mate [ __ ] hell yeah
he's no longer living in the UK he now
lives in Qatar yeah exactly he's moved
there uh Eric with the five dollars
let's get the America hat here we go
says how big of a Super Chat do you want
to see Francis do the Truffle Shuffle
attention Nathan Woodard
well we haven't heard from Nathan for
for a week or so I actually have a
little surprise for Nathan yeah I got
him something
um top bigger that he is
um yes uh
Francis how much money to do the Truffle
Shuffle mate
you send me 10 grand well I'll get it
done
10 grand right not don't send it to him
send it to us no send it to me
what'd you mean yeah you don't even have
a PayPal account
that's a good point to send it to me hey
I think Dave was a 690 yeah oh yes
because it is insulting to his people
he's just German not an actual Nazi no
do you think uh who do you think will be
in the world cup and why is it
Deutschland Mike I saw your boys against
Japan I thought you boys were supposed
to be allies yeah absolutely and the
Japanese what a game that was beautiful
they [ __ ] beat you anyway no I don't
think it's going to be Germany but you
can never ride off the Germans let's be
fair you've had some pretty woeful teams
in the past and they've ended up getting
to the final the Germans are very
efficient yeah when it comes to winning
stuff yeah they're very effective
they've still got some great clothes uh
I think you look you you can never write
off your voice
um I think it's going to be Spain I saw
a little snippet of their game against
Costa Rica [ __ ] me they look good
really good terrifyingly good
all right thank you hunting Jay I
appreciate the 690. Jake Kurtz for the
ten dollars Francis oh Jake ten dollars
big you too overdressed today gaming cam
response please
listen to me we're never [ __ ]
overdressed because we're English we're
gentlemen now put that in your pipe and
smoke it otherwise I'll make you [ __ ]
idiot [ __ ]
that Gammon camera is very red today it
is anyway uh thank you very much uh
Silas like oh we have we will do special
unboxing for Silas Larson because
Francis yeah I have another Viking head
oh yes Silas we have got a new Viking
hat for you oh yeah because it says here
to the good people of trigonometry thank
you for the Magnificent show here is a
Viking helmet and some Danish Suites for
you Lads from Rasmus roswed yeah you
haven't heard from for a while Erasmus
thank you very much I hope your bell
vasmos and there's a bunch of sweeties
in there of various kinds this skilled
padder
oh yes who doesn't like some skilled
powder uh should we try one live on air
yeah I'm up for a minute yeah let's try
one live on earth
exactly let's be fat again caramel fryer
whatever that is my who doesn't love her
to do a bit of caramel froya regada
all right so we're gonna try these
Danish sweets and we're going to tell
you we're going to give you a little
review on here what you think all right
the original Fruit and matzapan Plum in
Madeira strawberry and sparkling wine
all right mate I don't think they they
have in Liverpool mate yeah it's true
there we go let's have one of these all
right Tony do you want one mate
hmm
good
a little bit of alcohol now
front
jungle varal
and there's a monkey on the front
are you good yeah thank you very much
Roswell
why'd you take the helmet off it's the
best time that we've got me um
read the Super Chat
we are stuck with Anton due to the
problematic things you said to him
doesn't feel my [ __ ] fat head
England was kneeling before the Yankee
Masters as is correct yeah you've got a
point there mate thank you Silas much
appreciated
um oh yeah I need another hat Nathan
Woodard here he is six pounds 69 cents
for The Greatest Show on Earth keep it
up stay hard and if that is not working
work and stay harder more to
more to come more to come Nathan thank
you very much much appreciate it let's
get some U.S flags in the chat for
Nathan top level biggest is Nathan
Woodard let's get some American flags
let's get some turkeys let's get some
thanksgivings thank you very much Nathan
CRS where the two quizzes nice jacket
Francis I like the 1990 1998 as well so
do I I preferred 1998 because did we
have all this [ __ ] in 1998 did we have
[ __ ] pronouns did we have all this
gender woo-woo bollocks no we didn't
mate we're great music right we had
[ __ ] good football and we had respect
and we had and that was with days when
boys were boys and girls were girls you
could tell the [ __ ] difference
Francis coming from you who's credibly
accused of looking like Sue Perkins that
is a strange statement I know it's a
strange statement but back then I was an
aberration whereas now I'm the Norman
it's a [ __ ] disgrace that's true you
should be kept to a minority yeah or
should be that way I can tell people how
oppressed I am yeah CRS thank you for
the two quid much appreciated and you
you so
Marella these are Brazilian realities I
don't have a Brazilian house yeah we do
we have a Brazilian hat what do you mean
it's the same I was a Brazilian no no no
what about the Hat it's the same [ __ ]
thing all this time they don't even
speak the same language they speak
Portuguese
it's like your Dutch accent maybe what
are you doing mate they're all short fat
little brown people don't like doing a
day's work anyway have you seen some
Brazilian UFC fighters what about them
they're not short fat little people
they're massive tall people who'd smash
your face in for doing what you're doing
right now no I reckon I reckon Antoine
would defend me it is very sad to see
how surprised you guys seem to be when
you heard about Neymar supporting
bolsonaro remember to always doubt the
mainstream media and do your own
research now on you on your name uh
supported you so Marella has actually
written the same Brazil is not Mexico
we know we're we're joking around uh
yeah so I use are you saying Neymar
doesn't support bolsonaro I thought we
did I wasn't surprised actually at all I
just they were talking about it on TV
um but yeah uh thank you for the 20
Brazilian Reales we much appreciate it
I'm sorry for Francis insulting your
country by comparing you to Mexicans
Smiley Town SF with a four nine and nine
says great to see woke colonialism
failing Qatar colonialism and drag is
still colonialism
thank you smiley Town SF muchos
appreciadados oh Silas Larson do you
want to get the Viking hat or should I
wear mine
oh yes
yes I've got to do that so it fits on my
fat head uh those candles look like
candies candies look like post discharge
condom tips thanks Mike thanks mate
just a [ __ ] scandi yeah uh Amy valt
with a 499 hey boys I'm visiting my
friend in the Cayman Islands
you're doing all right love yes she's
doing all right [ __ ] came in on an
island what are you doing it's just
about money laundering yeah of course
you are [ __ ] and she says oh and I'm
introducing her to Raw uh welcome send
us look you've evaded enough taxes Amy's
friend right send us some proper Dosh
not 4.99. exactly can you say hello to
Ashley Ashley Hello send us more money
love exactly what's wrong with you right
put the your hand in that money
laundering pocket and give us some
[ __ ] dog you don't pay any taxes
anyway right we are the tax man give it
to me 33 effective tax rate exactly send
it over love
often that's got wrong side did you
reckon that that would win her over I
think so and I think what we've done
here is a PR masterclass yeah we have
because uh the
they love that she loves being the
gender but yeah yeah it's true she loved
being compared to it to uh to a Mexican
and uh and I think this this bird's
gonna send us her adoption I I think so
you know what I do I do have a lot of
admiration for Amy though because I'll
be honest with you if I had a mate that
I hadn't seen for a while yeah I went to
visit
and I do role for a living yeah I'm not
sure I'd show my mate raw you know I
wouldn't open with that I wouldn't be
like hey this is the degeneracy I've
been watching for the last two years to
avoid the misery of lockdown it's just
two retards on the internet putting
handsome doing weird accents for the
wrong country yeah exactly but it's not
racist welcome Ashley well great to have
you on the show thank you thank you very
much
uh Euro Marella says do your research
about bolsonaro I meant oh okay well
yeah we're familiar with with Boston now
to the extent yeah okay all right
perfect well thank you very much Francis
should we do I mean we've talked about
the football but yeah we'll catch
everybody up on what actually happened
in case they didn't watch it let's go to
that story Anton yeah we'll have a quick
read through it yeah let's watch it
because let's read about it because you
know what we want to remember it
uh the booze one
no beer but plenty of booze at England
versus USA number five
no sir
there we go no beer but plenty of booze
at England versus USA David Brown from
Doha yeah all right
and Tom
yeah oh here we go here we go the battle
between football and soccer which played
out last night in a Bedouin tent pitched
in the middle of the Qatar desert it
ended with a scoreless straw as boring
as the debate about the name of the game
more than 8 000 England fans packed into
the spectacular albate stadium in the
desert outside Alcoa about 20 miles from
Doha the manager Gara Southgate warned
his Squad would have to make history
with the USA having won and drawn their
two previous World Cup encounters they
now face Wales in a key match for both
teams none of the traveling England
supporters predicted defeat before
kickoff with many expecting the team to
go on to win the World Cup that doesn't
sound like England fans getting ahead of
themselves just because they beat Iran
6-2 they left the stadium less confident
after being [ __ ] yeah who's that
I mean that looks like cultural
appropriation a little bit I would say
yeah hopefully that's not one of the
players mate yeah keep scrolling and so
on there we go England's players did not
follow Germany's lead and covering their
Mouse to protest against FIFA Banning
European captains including Harry Kane
from wearing a rainbow armband the
Football Association instead lit the
arch at Wembley Stadium as a rainbow at
Wembley Stadium where nobody was there
were plenty of empty seats in Alcoa
despite FIFA recording a crowd of just
432 fewer than the 69 000 capacity uh
the USA fans appeared not to have
forgotten the Revolution and booed
include supporters rendition of God save
the king during the match England
responded in coin when the Americans
sang A tuneless I believe that we will
win that is a [ __ ] song that only
Americans would sing uh but I thought
what is that song I don't know but it's
a [ __ ] song that only American thing uh
David Beckham the former England captain
now employed by Qatar to promote tourism
was in the stadium alongside many of the
players wives girlfriends and children
as gay men were let out and executed in
front of him exactly uh both sets of fun
I always
the future of both England and Wales
could depend on the result when they
meet on Tuesday
uh Jamie Tommy uh an electrician from
Worcester said okay now it's squeaky bum
time against Wales no I wouldn't use
that sort of language in katame yeah
exactly I knew this would be a much
tighter game than the Iran one is he
just doing sexualized puns yeah yeah he
is squeaky bum time mate is it going to
be a tighter game uh before the match I
was predicting 2-1 to England
and there we go hundreds of England
supporters made the 4 000 mile Journey
to the Middle East after the opening 62
defeat of Iran despite 1500 pound
flights soaring accommodation prices and
tickets going for two and a half
thousand pounds Mark Davis from Crystal
Palace South London said I'm still
confident although you can't
underestimate any of the other teams I
think you can underestimate guitar mate
there's [ __ ] back home Diplomat in the
US Embassy in London cheered the special
relationship was saved after the nil nil
draw a little pack of [ __ ] virgins uh
scores of consulate workers and some U.S
Marines piled into the embassy's private
Pub to watch a World Cup Showdown
uh the pub stole like an American Sports
Bar overlooks the Thames and usually
closes at about 7 P.M course it does
it's not a proper [ __ ] bar because
there's Americans in it but was open
late to host a viewing party for the
game uh John Harley the U.S ambassador
oh sorry Jane Hawk I mean I I it's a
natural mistake to make
yeah they shouldn't be allowed mate Jane
Harley the U.S ambassador told the times
that World Cup fever had spread
throughout the building no matter the
outcome England in the United States
will still be the closest of friends and
allies yeah it's because it's a game of
football love yeah anyway Anton we leave
it there it was a [ __ ] game uh I think
we've covered it well enough and well
but before we move on I've got a lovely
little video for you that will warm the
cockles of your heart is it the
highlights from last night no it's not
the highlights from last night because
because there weren't there were no
highlights right last night however the
Welsh they didn't have a good game they
went to play Iran and Iran beat them two
nil Wells deservedly had a player sent
off for violence uh with who did a
flying against the Iranians anyway
here is some postmap root Max reaction
from the Welsh fans after the game here
we go okay I'm human about this
I watched like a hundred minutes and I'm
human mate I can't believe this I am
disappointed but Wales did good but I
guess they're just better that's life I
don't know how like we had like two
minutes left and they've scored two
goals and I'm really disappointed now
the outside I just feel great but but on
the inside just it just hurts part of
Wales to be the World Cup but I think
that's it now they're out
you know what they've actually had more
dignity than he held in the [ __ ] real
fans of wandering around committing
whatever yeah there you go I feel great
on the outside but sad on the inside but
inside it just hurts oh see this is the
problem with having having my son now I
actually start to like kids yeah to hate
the [ __ ] yeah I mean you're quite
right to hate the [ __ ] but anyway
they're annoying they are ugly they are
then you have your own yeah and then you
sort of go yeah oh sweet someone says
why do you have subtitles because
they're Welsh yeah you can't understand
them they're foreign
anyway Patricia bottomley with 8.99 keep
up with the bigger tree loads great show
I don't know why I did you anyway let's
put it a shot oh Bradley Ness We're The
Kids Americans I reckon that's Bradley
knees thanks Bradley appreciate the
tenor uh Dave McIntosh good to see you
in Norwich FFF Dane thanks for that mate
thanks for coming down what a bloody
brilliant show that was what great night
we all had in Norwich I got two more
shows coming up in Leicester and
Stafford come and see me Francis
foster.co.uk I'm doing it with Leo curse
as well
it's going to be absolutely brilliant
the show's been great people have loved
it so come down all right uh Anton oh BJ
Allen with the 20 Euro says with the
England versus USA draw what happens now
with James Corden and Megan and Harry I
reckon we split split we've got to split
the difference mate I reckon they keep
Harry and James and then I get to keep
Megan
I mean I'm not against that as long as
they keep cordon and Harry you can do
whatever you want with Megan as long as
she's not allowed to talk yeah
no I mean she'll be kept busy
cooking
she's probably [ __ ] come on do you know
what she's probably terrible mate she's
never probably she's never cooked a meal
in her life I'd imagine she like
I couldn't go out with with a bird he
can't cook mate
can do it what about Megan
you only eat salad anyway nowadays no no
I mean not salad what do you eat now I
sort of just lamb chops and greens yeah
meat and greens basically yeah
it's not hard to cook you can cook it
yourself
can I might
you put me right off her now well
Francis you don't like Megan anymore
because she can't cook she can't cook we
don't know if she can't cook I'm just
hypothesizing here yeah she doesn't look
like she like no no no no no no no she
don't she she probably has some vegan
salad [ __ ] every day you know what as
well to look after her figure in that
she looks like the type of Lady mate who
sees uh sex as a bit of unnecessary
squelching once a month I don't know if
I find that appealing
where did you get that from
I'm just projecting now because you've
ruined her I I haven't I I haven't said
anything mate I I'm part of this car
crash section of Raw tonight what do you
mean no fault on my own would you mean
car crash section what do you mean what
do I mean you've just insinuated that
Meghan Markle can't cook and that's why
you don't want to Shanker anymore right
now and then you've suggested that she
wouldn't shag you anyway because she's
not she's basically a bit frigid is what
you're saying I'm not saying that that
is exactly what you said I'm not I just
translated it into human language no I'm
not I'm not I want this is outrageous
mate I hope sees this I will not have my
complex arguments being
being debased in such reductive terms
no it's not right solving Mike with a
five dollars thank you very much much
appreciated moving on swiftly before
this gets out of hand June hope were
there in 99 says what I don't understand
is they don't seem to care about the
slaves the ground they kneel on
literally built by slaves the work have
managed the impossible they ruined
football well this is it too they don't
none of their arguments seem to have any
logic it's all virtual signaling we know
that and it just makes it just looks a
bit tiresome if we've got enough to cook
time we'll put a clip from John Barnes
in there which just sums the whole thing
up beautifully actually
um
it's only a 30 second clip Anton let's
get up John Barnes sums it up
beautifully here June hope see what you
think football can't change people's
perspective life changes your
perspective these football changing
perspective here because the players
took a knee no you have to look at it
from an Institutional point of view from
a societal point of view from a moral
intellectual point of view from a
colonial point of view in terms of what
we believe in others believe but I
believe that if you go to somebody's
country because we're saying the same
thing for people who come here who may
not believe in our laws or believe that
they're right they have to respect our
Lords while they're here so if we don't
want to respect their laws do not go if
footballers don't feel or they feel they
want to do something be it an armband be
it outspoken and not allowed to make a
stand and say I'm not going because I
really believe in this but they really
don't we
well get to know the John Barnes watches
raw yeah quoting us yeah exactly good
yeah well said Tim yeah well done Johnny
the bonds she's completely on point in
it he is indeed uh Francis shall we talk
about the headline story that we've
picked for the title today which is of
course uh the firemen are evil and
sexist yeah are they racist as well
called say oh of course they are made
some of this uh culture of racism
bullying and misogyny revealed in London
fire brigade
stomach turning stories are spelled out
in an 88-page report that says abuse and
bullying are normalized in the emergency
service in London
there we go uh when Sophie a female
firefighter walked past male colleagues
they would taunt her about her weight by
imitating the sound of a truck reversing
Anton's laughing his head off
I mean that sounds like the sort of
thing I would do to you mate yeah it's
true isn't that just a bit of banter
though surely
between colleagues I mean it depends on
the context yeah it does depend on the
context I personally wouldn't do that to
a lady no I wouldn't either because I'm
not into fat shaming women it's only men
that you're allowed to fetch him but in
that sort of environment there's all
sorts of banter always going on you know
what I mean see this is the thing and
this one also you can't have fat
firefighters it should be prohibited oh
no because then they'll just be like
they're gonna get stuck in that little
thing that they go down oh otherwise or
they'll clog up the thing just like the
arteries that is true but it's also as
well when you were judging an emergency
service when you were talking about
people who were literally on the front
line of the Emergency Services their
sense of humor their sense of what is
right and what is wrong when it comes to
jokes has been warped by the fact that
they're quite to put it quite bluntly
they've all seen too much and their
humor is a way is is incredibly dark as
a way of coping with the horrific themes
that they've seen in their line of work
yeah are your biggest fan uh Kathy uh
kidson says why are you only allowed to
Fat shame women a lot no no you've
misunderstood what I'm saying you're not
allowed to Fat shame women yeah you're
only allowed to Fat shame men yeah right
because Birds can't handle it yeah they
start crying yeah future now says KK fat
shames FF every day yeah Anton no no
hide the story right look at him look
how much weight he's lost look how much
happy he is look at his happy little
face he's just changed it just for you
to pretend to be grumpy he actually
loves it he loves being slim he loves
being healthy he loves not eating carbs
don't you Francis no I don't Mike
exactly you do tell them how much you
love it [ __ ] all that fat shaming is
for his health right
his children will thank me for all the
fat shaming I've done to save him from
his inevitable fate
I miss ravioli you're not having ravioli
mate let me see yeah good you're allowed
to miss it right but anyway you can't
fashion Birds because it's you know they
stop it's just all like crying and
everything yeah exactly you can't handle
it you've got to get the tissues out and
stuff
anyway let's keep reading the story
Anton then there was our time at the
London fire brigade when our helmet was
filled with urine now that is disgusting
and the moment she found herself zipped
in a body inside a body bag as part of a
practical joke now obviously
I imagine this happens to most
firefighters as part of The Hazing
rituals to get them into the thing it
happens it was part of rugby players who
join Rugby teams it happens with
footballers like you hear about you know
they zipped her up inside of a body bag
that sounds like what they would do to
anybody when they join however having
said that if I came in here and this
jacket was filled with your Pierce I'd
probably be a bit upset about it you
know what I mean yeah and if you were
like oh it's just a bit of hazing KK I'd
[ __ ] Haze you right there you know
what I mean so I mean that's not nice is
it no carry on
the experiences contributed to Sophie
not her real name being diagnosed with
PTSD looking back she compares her time
at work to being in an abusive
relationship
her anecdotes along with others dozens
of other examples of racism bullying and
misogyny will form part of a damning
88-page investigation published tomorrow
which will reveal the toxic culture in
the country's largest fire service
details include a black employee finding
a noose above his locker while a Muslim
firefighter had a terrorism hotline
sticker placed near his belongings when
when the man returned
from the Hajj pilgrimage to Saudi Arabia
colleagues asked how his Al-Qaeda
training had gone is Banter yeah they
love
you see
right now that is disgusting yeah right
the former Crown Crown uh Chief Crown
prosecutor in the Rochdale grooming gang
case who was asked to conduct the lfb
independent review the stories he
overheard he heard over many months was
stomach turning although afso emphasized
that our review is rooted in deep
respect for the work of ollfb Staff he
concluded that the Brigade was
institutionally misogynistic and racist
everything is nowadays tea is racist
anyway absal and his team conducted 250
interviews with former and current staff
as well as a dozen focus groups more
than 100 written submissions were
received and service completed by 1600
employees the report titled the
independent cultural review of London
fire brigade and obtained by the Sunday
Times was commissioned following the
death of Jaden Francois Spirit a trainee
at Wembley fire station who took his own
life age 21 in August 2020. charging
yeah and anyways last year heard that
Francois Spirit believed he was being
bullied at work because of his ethnicity
with claims that he was teased about the
Caribbean food he bought him for lunch
he made 16 requests to be transferred to
another station delivering her conclude
okay so this is obviously the sad part
of the story yeah this guy killed
himself and it's tragic and shouldn't
have happened
um and Lantern let's leave it there and
we'll talk about look I think one of the
things this is about well first of all
clearly some of the stuff that they've
described as completely unacceptable
yeah other stuff though it's like I mean
it is part of the culture of that sort
of environment yeah and it seems to me
like you know Society is changing people
are becoming more sensitive and you've
got this process where uh maybe some old
habits that would have like you and I
probably wouldn't bat an eyelid at
are now you know I mean if you look at
them
in The Cold Light of Day
they would be considered bullying
without yeah of course you know but it
brings also as well you know the problem
is
some of these words if you take them out
of context they sound awful yeah but if
you it depends on the context now
there's certain things like smearing of
semen you know filling up a helmet with
urine obviously disgusting and shouldn't
have happened but some of the it's very
difficult with these reports to
ascertain what was a joke and everybody
was fine with and what it was meant to
her well think of all the stuff that we
say to each other and after Anton on the
show right like she could easily claim
he's being bullied for his ethnicity
at all yeah until he realizes but we we
can both deck us at the same time he
could take us both at the same time he
could my point is right he could claim
he's being bullied because of his
ethnicity I could claim that I'm being
bullied because of my ethnicity you
could claim that you're being bullied
you know for body what image reasons or
whatever right
and none of that's true it's just banter
yeah you know what I mean so it's it
just seems to me like Society is
changing around us and I don't like it
don't [ __ ] agree with it and as as
well as I said these types of
environments are going to have much
darker jokes because of the nature of
the work these people do
they're Frontline responders
completely agree we've got a couple of
paypals as well but obviously the fact
that this poor man ended up committing
suicide is awful yeah of course and you
know and some of these some of the
stories were disgusting and that should
be eliminated uh Laura's mother
messaging says after spending almost 10
years working in a prison surrounded by
men I can say that that is nothing I'm
assuming she's she's talking about the
reversing comments yeah I mean I did
laugh at that yeah
then that is my sense of humor yeah all
right Anton if you've got a super chance
to pull them up and I've got some paper
silence Larson oh
yeah you have your own oh yes I have my
own but I like to wear that one because
I get the glasses anyway they're my fat
head if I had a name as fine as bottomly
I'd walk around in the buff more uh more
often
what does the vest do when it is time
for you for Ukraine to retake Crimea uh
we will cross that bridge I use that
term deliberately when we come to it we
will see I mean look the the big uh
meltdowns on various social medias up to
date in the war in Ukraine has been like
oh if Ukraine starts to push Russia out
then the nuclear Wars goodness and
that's never happened right Russia
declared the Hassan era for example uh
part of Russia ukrainians took it back
uh nothing's happened so uh I'm not
persuaded that the West should worry too
much about it having said that I do
think Ukraine should be careful about
Crimea because the Strategic importance
of Crimea to Russia is very very high
um and so I do think they would be
willing to do things that they otherwise
wouldn't be willing to do uh in order to
protect it um so
as I said at the beginning of the war
and a lot of people didn't like it uh
including on the Ukrainian side which I
broadly support as you know
um I would stay away from Crimea if I
was Ukraine do you think I can't imagine
the ukrainians going
to cry me why not because it's a deeply
antagonistic gesture well they're a war
so but but in perspective they're
fighting an enemy of what do they give a
[ __ ] about being antagonistic
the winning in the war but I mean
I agree with you but
by deeply antagonistic you
pushing the Russians that I've heard of
song is one thing right
but
liberating Crimea is something else
entirely and that is that is by deeply
antagonistic what I mean is that is
how can I put this that is even more
likely to for the Russians to then want
to do something
even more extreme in order to try and
take it back no I agree with you uh but
I'm I'm just saying from a Ukrainian
perspective it looks very differently
Ukraine has almost no electricity right
now uh the Water Supply is disrupted
sewage is disrupted heating is disrupted
so Russia is deliberately making the
lives of uh tens of millions of
Ukrainian civilians miserable yeah uh as
part of this war killing raping
murdering Etc you can see why they may
not care about
antagonistic gestures yeah that's true
you know uh so uh Silas we will have to
wait and see I'm afraid uh thank you
very much for that and I'd say well
we've got some paypals as well let's see
let's see the papers uh Mary senator
says sorry the U.S England game was such
a drag for you Lads that's what you get
when you play against the workers
country in the world yeah when you play
England uh and Elizabeth the Senator's
20 quid and no comment Elizabeth thank
you very much much appreciated thank you
so much for that France um Elizabeth
and Francis yes what would you like us
to talk about next we have got that we
have got a lot to talk about we've only
got 15 minutes but we should we have 50
minutes until we go to locals yeah last
half an hour as always yes indeed Anton
Vanessa is sent in a Super Chat yep
let's have a look at this she says only
fit firemen any race must be able to
lift
there we go I mean yeah sorry go on so
uh should we do a little bit of a
political one because I think it's quite
interesting yeah should we do number
eight
what's that
Nigel farage says Tories deserve to be
Mike wiped out as migration hits record
high
there he is Nigel and Nigel farage said
the conservative party deserves to be
wiped out after net migration to the UK
hit a new record high of 500 504 000.
the number for 12 months to June this
year was revealed by the office of
national statistics this morning it is
770 000 more than the previous post-war
record of 331 000 in 2015. uh Mr farage
the former leader of the brexit party
said these net migration figures are
hard to take in 500 000 is nearly double
the previous record deserve the Tories
deserve to be wiped out
the ons said uh the 504 000 figure was
the result of an unprecedented
combination of events including the end
of covert lockdown restrictions of war
in Ukraine with the surging visas for
foreign Nationals to live study and work
in the UK
the record high will pile pressure on
the government with Rishi sunak having
recently insisted he wants to see a
reduction in overall migration levels a
long-standing Tory pledge that's never
been honored uh Downing Street said at
lunchtime that the prime minister is
fully committed to Bringing overall
numbers down and the public rightly
expect us to deliver control over our
borders so there we go okay so I think
that story is interesting for a number
of things so the migration we've already
tapped into we talked about yesterday
but there are rumors that he's going to
make a comeback Nigel yeah well he was
talking about uh reform standing
candidates everywhere and not doing a
deal with with the Tories I'll be honest
with you I actually don't think the even
though the Tories are not doing well I
don't think reform would do well at this
election how come
I I I just don't I mean it's really hard
for as Nigel has said himself on our
show it's very hard for third parties I
also think
um I actually as you know my position on
immigration I've always been more
um restrictionist I think out of the two
of us or maybe more more restrictionist
than most people on immigration I
actually do think that this year is not
necessarily a good example of failed
immigration policy I think previously
we've had uh very very big problems what
we have now is the accumulation of those
big problems and the Hong Kong refugees
and the Ukraine refugees you take those
out of it it's a pretty standard year
very bad badly managed here but
nonetheless standard so
um but no I I'm not sure that
I'm not sure that there's a massive
appetite in the country to uh there's an
appetite possibly to get rid of the
Tories I don't think there's a large
number of people who are going to vote
for reform you don't think there's no no
even if farage was to lead them which I
don't think he will
so do you think it's because they're not
an established brand even like for
instance for example ukip
I don't think I don't think you would
get a massive number of people voting
for you could put the next election
either I mean look the next election is
so far away you can't predict any of it
but if there was election today I think
labor would win I think Tories would
come second I think reform probably
wouldn't get a single seat hmm
but might need to get enough in order to
Sting the Tories yeah Oh They'll
probably do that for sure but I don't
think that's going to be necessary labor
will win if there was an election now
yeah I know people are saying in the
chat I'm voting reform I get it I get it
but I don't think you're a
representative of the country yeah there
we go
uh there we go indeed lovely let's see
some super Chatters please actually a
lot of people in the chat disagreeing
with me yeah and that's because they are
going to vote for reform and I get it
I'm just saying I don't think the
majority of the country will vote sdp
yeah if they stand the candidate in your
area which they probably don't uh
Blenheim Duchess with it Five paulers
lotto thank you very much
foreignly says I try to live up to my
name as often as I can thank you very
good
um let's go to Story number seven
because this is [ __ ] outrageous me
[ __ ] outrageous have a look at this
it's a disgrace
Hair India Airline tells board and grain
cabin crew to smarten up see if we work
for Hair India mate we'd both be in
trouble oh look at that overweight staff
also inside something no you know what I
changed my mind these people are great
the new owners of Air India are trying
to turn around the fortunes of the
struggling flag carrier with boarding
and overweight crew members first to be
targeted these boys don't [ __ ] about do
they the debt written Airline was
brought by the Tata group and an Indian
was bought rather by the Tata group an
Indian conglomerate earlier this year
and it is now undergoing an overhaul to
improve its poor reputation new rules
for cabin crew ban balding men from
trying to hold on to a receiving Airline
they've been ordered to shave their
heads and go bald for a cleaner look the
rules are outlined in a 40-page booklet
which goes into detail over every aspect
of the crew's appearance the rules are
stringent crew were receding headline
and male body patches must keep a clean
shaved hair Bond Look hair must be
shaved daily crew cut is not permitted
haircuts must be neat with a side
parting and use and the use of hair gel
is mandatory as is a daily shave
assuring the natural look the airline is
told all crew members who have gray hair
or starting to go gray to dye it
regularly but only with a natural color
and certainly none of the Vivid camera
orange henna which some Indians favor
the female crew members blonde hair
blonde hair streaks High Top Knots and
low buns resting on the neck or out what
you can't be blonde no
because you're Indian mate
you've got to be you've got to have your
natural black hair what about diversity
though mate no
I guess they don't do diverse no I don't
all right worried that in an emergency
overweight crew members might be less
than Nimble down the aisle the airline
has ordered BMI index BMI and weight
checks
oh people after my own heart cabin crew
unions objected saying that asking the
crew to step onto the scales at airports
dehumanized and denigrated stuff it is
not the first time the airline has
struggled with overweight staff on
several occasions while it was
state-owned it ordered overweight cabin
crew to stop Flying and work as ground
staff instead Banks can't take off
either there we go well Francis you know
if you wanted to shave your head because
you're going gray or if I wanted to
shave my head because I'm going bog you
know what we could use well manscape
everybody yes manscape I mean they're
not mainly for the head they're not
tough but manscape manscape proudly
sponsored trigonometry roles and
trigonometry shows and with our code you
can actually get 20 off or it's Black
Friday as well another 25 off with them
so our code is trigger 20. go to
manscaped.com and you can get the right
tools for the job absolutely and they've
come with a wide range of accessories
you you don't also get the trimmer you
get a range of deodorants they give you
a free pair of boxes plus you get the
weed whacker and that is a nasal trimmer
so you can so if you've got the old 40
years old middle-aged man Forest growing
up you know stick that up there trim it
you'll have a nut you'll have a nasal
hair like a 10 year old exactly
that sounds a bit creepy yeah but anyway
uh flip more by the way uh says it does
establish titles still sponsor the show
so a bunch of you raised this issue on
locals uh where you should be if you
want to watch the last time yes because
we're going to be doing a stream but
it's only going to be for our fans on
locals so if you want to watch the last
half an hour of all the good stuff you
better be on locals that's right
okay anyway he's saying does established
titles still sponsor trigonometry uh we
looked into it uh we're not comfortable
with what they turned out to be so the
way we book ads is we have a company
that does it for us they're supposed to
do all of the filtering and making sure
that we don't get any uh dubious or
dodgy advertisers unfortunately this one
is kind of it's like a 50 50 call they
are sort of like they're not it's not
really a scam but it's not quite what it
says on the tent so for that reason we
won't be accepting ads from them anymore
um thank you for I think it was Kieran
that raised that on locals uh and making
us aware of it we got the Harmony on it
he looked into it gave us the
information and we've asked uh uh the
company that does our ads not to sell
ads to them again but we are delighted
to be sponsored by the Qatari petroleum
company uh
says what the [ __ ] is locals well there
is a link in the description and Anton
can probably put it in the chat for you
as well it is basically like patreon but
there is a community with it so it's
like a closed Facebook group for
trigonometry fans you get to see the
memes that other people post you can
interact with other fans who you see
here in the chat we are regularly on
there posting stuff you get bonus
content yeah if you support us at higher
levels you get additional benefits you
can join our monthly calls you can uh
you know get access to our supporter
only streams on there and all sorts of
other cool stuff so if you want to
support the show or if you want to enjoy
more stuff related to the show locals is
the place to be and unlike uh places
like PayPal which we have to use because
we can't find a better alternative at
the moment uh they actually do believe
in allowing people uh to to to to have
their Community anywhere they want and
to allow creators like us to set the
rules we want for our community and if
we want people to be able to say what
they want then that's what happens so
make sure you join locals if you want to
to support the show timbuk says can I
buy a coffee mug of course go to
triggerpod.co.uk forward slash shop and
you can buy merch there or if you
support us at 25 a month on locals we
will post you among ourselves one of
these slags uh and we'll be and these
are the trigonometry Classics we'll
begin the new logo uh on onto the monks
going forward yeah but so you can get
the old school because there is no
school like the old school indeed uh
we've got to pay paleo from Arvid
Harvard
indeed oh my God he's a [ __ ] Aussie
anyway yeah yeah so what has he said
well the email hasn't come through there
it is what is he said Mike let's have a
look it goes so I woke up early to watch
Raw it normally starts at 6 a.m here
yesterday uh oh yeah so I was woke up
early to watch Raw yesterday he normally
starts at 6 a.m here he moved it back an
hour for sports ball sorry about that
mate we'll try not to do it again yeah
but it was necessary at the time you
know what I can't imagine hmm
watching Raw at 6am no can I that is
quite incredible you guys have a lot of
dedication to the show to wake up at 6am
to watch Raw exactly
there we go thank you very much
do we have any super chants we need to
oh yes we do do we yeah
no we didn't no we didn't we need to do
that one let's bring that one up please
Tony uh Tabata arvinson oh yeah so no
that is Danish we can't have Danish we
need device oh yes
there we go
the top is [ __ ] up Crossing carton was
a chance to redeem themselves
have [ __ ] up many times
it just yeah they've been absolutely
useless [ __ ] them
I'm looking at these videos you put in
Francis there's any good ones oh yeah
short ones yeah oh well there's there's
one which is four minutes but we can
watch the first two minutes of it well
the Ryan long one yeah yesterday yeah
you didn't have any sound yeah and Anton
silenced it here we go let's watch a
couple of minutes of this because Ryan
is very funny former guest of the show
here we go very excited to be working
together again Jordan uh the bit of a
departure from the usual and the
publishing us maybe just wanted to get
into your creative process of what you
were thinking when you wrote 12 rules
for crushing [ __ ] well I've spent some
time on the internet and it opened my
bloody eyes to what these 304s are up to
you mentioned 304s there's sixes just
like they think they deserve a
millionaire I don't know they need to
learn the harsh reality that I shouldn't
be obligated to call them in the morning
and it's not because my phone's broken
it works just fine yeah I feel like we
just had a pretty good thing going on
here with the post-modernism trans stuff
telling the truth why don't you ask a
girl her body count and see who's
actually telling the truth quite the
opposite of it women crave leadership
and dominance from a high value Manner
and I'm a high value man there's no
doubt about that yeah sir are we just
trying to get away from the whole
traditional conservative values but it's
not obvious I shouldn't be allowed to
get some side tail it's an ornate nature
to lay pipe even the words lay and pipe
have Union connotation so you're a
married man well sure you're going to
get some pushback from your wife like
who is this girl why are you cheating on
me but what is cheating really what
precisely do you mean by the word who
yeah I don't know what do you mean by me
no really it's a complicated problem
we're not going to solve it overnight
then you do decide to leave me what
happens then you end up with some soy
boy who's begging you to recycle well
good luck with that I just feel like
we're messing with a money printer here
these hoes ain't loyal okay sometimes
you find out she was wasn't even yours
to begin with it was just your turn and
now that as JP's turn with your girl
that's a hard girl to swallow I go over
that in my chapter the art of the steel
yeah about that I don't know if your
audience is going to love you talking
about stealing their women the girls
don't belong to you anyway they're for
the streets and why shouldn't top P get
a taste taste these women like to
pretend that they're not like other
girls but I've got news for you you're
exactly like other girls and I'll be
damned if I have to pretend that you're
special now John let me ask you a quick
question if you by chance been listening
to Andrew Tate recently or Kevin Sammy
no not familiar because you had a whole
chapter called maps of meeting which
sounds like you but then it's just a map
of clubs you can meet thoughts in Miami
okay I'll admit it
the kids are listening to Peterson
anymore I'm trying to get with the times
that was funny yeah a very good from
Ryan there Anton let us catch up on the
final super chats for the night and we
will head over to locals for supporter
only stream we get to ask us any
questions you want Millie Smith with the
five Canadians oh my God dropping in to
say hi see you boys on locals and Anton
I think we've got another one from
Nathan that we might have missed
Nathan Woodard with a 69 69 for The
Greatest Show on Earth please take it
and blow it for all times sake Nathan
thank you very much we will do so let's
get some American flags in the chat for
the wonderful Nathan top level bigot
Woodard uh and ush oh so no one now that
Francis has managed to put the fork down
uh you should both you should both turn
up growth ashes do the accent and have
that Indian airline sponsor the show we
will do so yeah uh guys thank you oh we
got one more Smiley Town SF with the
five American dollars Anton give it to
me I feel bad for England being tied
with the USA you guys know soccer here
is basically the realm of brats and wine
moms I know that I did make that point
earlier uh thank you very much
smileytown SF thank you all of you we
will see you on locals in a couple of
minutes uh be patient as we switch over
take care we will see you then
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean are executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
a lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and